I was going to say
um you you're in a weird space because
there's a gift and a curse to being who
you are because you're like my kids and
like even Bravo the bag Chaser who was
here before you he's like yo that dude's
hilarious and I was like yeah his album
just dropped you know and he was like he
raps yeah I was like like at a high
level
so like that's a great thing to me
because you have like I mean you've
hosted the crew League I mean there's so
many bags you're getting just based on
you being you that's the best part music
aside yeah like I'm nems you're here
because I'm hilarious but for you as
like an emcee is it ever like um
frustrating where you gotta like educate
people that you're a rapper because
you're like oh gee dog like I look at it
I love it it's like it's like becoming a
new artist all over again
um and I know that if they see me there
with the comedy [__] the funny [__]
they're gonna be turned on at some point
to seeing me rap and it's not like my
raps are [__] like I'm not I'm
saying it as humbly as possible like I
could rap you know what I'm saying so
you're gonna see something of me like oh
[__] I didn't even know and then so for
you it's like one hand washes the other
absolutely because you have like two
audiences and if like hey no rapper is
touching my demographic like I'm known
by people three years old to 70 years
old
all Races wherever I go no rapper got
that demographic no for sure
has there uh what I love is when you my
favorite [__] on the internet the last
like decade is you've making fun of
people uh while they walk by don't ever
disrespect me it's the best [__] ever uh
who did I just see acknowledge your [__]
but they didn't know your name there was
oh Roseanne Roseanne it was Roseanne she
was on Theo Bond yes yes she was like
talking about you no mad people sent me
that yeah she was talking about you but
she didn't know who you were she was
like you ever you see this guy that
don't don't you that she was like doing
your whole bit I love that how crazy is
that to have Roseanne Barr [__]
acknowledge you crazy shout out to
Roseanne she's a ghost
let her give me a [__]
yeah like I always say that like you
know it's about all about the story
facts yeah
I mean chosen Roseanne was jerking off
[__] Tom Arnold in the 90s bro I
definitely got a shot no I think I think
Roseanne would manually stimulate you
like they should let me beat I think so
did you DM her nah maybe I should I
think I mean she knows who you are now
all you got to do is hit her with the DM
and say hey Roseanne thank you for the
love no I don't ever stop me
not knowing my name you owe me a hand
job now yeah you know what I'm saying I
mean if you got a Roseanne hand job that
would be uh I mean honestly like I might
I might post it on the gram
yeah just that's clout yeah spit no spit
Lube raw dog raw dog you ever have a
chick uh I always say uh
you ever go to a restaurant and they
give you the salt and pepper I always
say uh that's sexually that's the tell
me when to stop
when the waitress is over your plate
tell me when to stop
hahaha
yeah you know what I'm saying when you
got that goddamn that pepper grinder
gear you know I mean you know you know
what I saw last night who knew who I was
and was like very like
engaged in like wanting me to come on
her show
Alexis Texas do you remember Alexis
Texas she wanted me to come on her [__]
too
and her show as well
[Music]
and I was he looks way better in person
yes than she does on the gram or in the
movies so she shook my hand and she was
like Hey and she's cool super nice so
she was like hey Alexis Texas
and I was like
oh you are Alexis Texas
I was with her probably
a month ago wow a Soho saw her right at
the comic came out scram Jones Studio My
Man album was with a was like yo she
wants you to be on the podcast I'm like
all right
she has a popular podcast but let her
know we don't hold no punches we're
gonna be talking crazy yeah she was like
Bring It On